DANIEL GALPIN: Hi, I'm Dan
Galpin, and with me is Bruno
Oliveira and Todd Kerpelman.
And today, we're going to be
talking about the top seven
developer mistakes people
make in setting
up Google Play services.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: So our show
today is going to be entirely
about mistakes.
DANIEL GALPIN: Your mistakes.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
DANIEL GALPIN: So before we
start talking about your
mistakes, let's do a little
summary of what Google Play
game services actually are.
This, of course, is Google's
backend to do achievements and
leader boards, real time
multiplayer, cloud save, as
well as some anti-piracy
features that are on Android,
to help you game developers
implement best-of-breed
services scaling to
Google scale.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
And I think especially with a
real time multiplayer, I mean,
this is one big piece of
infrastructure that we are
taking into our own hands so
that you can actually focus on
what makes your games awesome.
DANIEL GALPIN: Yeah.
Instead of writing all that
boring infrastructure code,
let us write the boring code.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: We like
boring stuff.
DANIEL GALPIN: Yea, exactly.
And we like thinking about
scale, and you guys
can think about fun.
And I think that's a good way
of dividing things up.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yeah, exactly.
So with that, let's dive
into our list of
top 7 developer mistakes.
First of all, let's talk about
using the JAR file instead of
the library project.
As you know, when you're using
Google Play game services, you
have to include the Google Play
services library project.
And then if you're using our
samples, you have to include
the BaseGameUtils
library project.
The mistake that some developers
do is thinking that
library projects actually don't
mean anything, and they
can just include
the JAR files.
Well, JAR files are just
classes, while library
projects are something that
wraps classes and resources
into the same bundle.
So the worst thing is that they
won't really notice if
they make this mistake.
DANIEL GALPIN: Yeah.
We don't actually go and
validate the APK to make sure
the resources are there that
you're actually referencing
when you're doing one
of these projects.
That JAR file actually contains
references to
resources that we're providing
in that library project, and
if you don't put those resources
in, there's nothing
in the compiler, there's
nothing in the deck, so
there's nothing in the packager
that's actually going
to catch that mistake.
Who going to catch
that mistake?
Your users are going to
catch that mistake.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
And you might not even catch it
during testing because the
only place where you're going to
see this mistake is if the
library actually wants to use
a resource from that bundle.
And that's going to happen,
for example, when the user
can't sign in and it has
to show a dialog box.
So ironically enough, when the
library is trying to show an
error message, then it's going
to figure out that it doesn't
have that resource.
And then it's going to have to
show an error message saying
that it can't show their
message, and it's going to
look something like that.
I mean, that's everyone's
favorite screen.
DANIEL GALPIN: Absolutely.
And the best part is it's
not a crash in our code.
It looks like a crash
in your code.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: It's going
to totally look
like it's your fault.
DANIEL GALPIN: Or
your mistake.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Or
DANIEL GALPIN: So there's
mistake number seven.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
DANIEL GALPIN: So I think we
should take it over to Todd
Kerpelman, who is in Studio
I. Todd, are you there?
TODD KERPELMAN: Hi, I'm here.
Yeah, sorry.
I'm getting a little
tape delay.
I'm kind of far away.
But I'll try and stay current.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And now we're
going to use our confidential
teleporting technology to pass
this laptop all the way over
to Studio I.
TODD KERPELMAN: All
right, thanks.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: There we go.
That worked.
Is it the same laptop?
TODD KERPELMAN: It is, in
fact, the same laptop.
DANIEL GALPIN: That's our
Pixelante at work here.
TODD KERPELMAN: There you go.
This is a pretty laptop.
That wasn't a product plug.
It really is a nice laptop.
DANIEL GALPIN: It is.
It's beautiful.
TODD KERPELMAN: So our next
mistake is using the Google
APIs Console instead of the
Google Play Developer Console.
And let's explain why this
matters and why you care.
On the backend, we've got a set
of games services, right?
And we also have on their
backend a whole bunch of other
API-related stuff.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And that's
a technical term.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's
That's what we call
it, API stuff.
So the other API stuff is
generally set up using the
Google APIs Developer Console.
If you have added any Google
services in the past,
generally on the web, but
certainly other devices, you
may have seen this Developer
Console.
It's at
code.google.com/api/console.
Game services is generally
set up-- oh, sorry.
And yes, this is generally where
you would set up your
OAuth 2.0 client IDs, you could
review your quotas, you
could add other team members
to your project, and so on.
The game services are
generally set up and
administered through the Google
Play Developer Console.
This is the developer console
that you would be used to
visiting if you're an Android
developer, but iOS and web
guys, you're going to
have to go here too.
At the Game Services Console,
this is where you would set up
your leader boards, your
achievements, and then also
where you would associate
these leader boards and
achievements with the
OAuth 2.0 client IDs
that you set up.
So how does this work?
In general, the Game Services
Developer Console manages all
this for you.
I go, I visit the Developer
Console, and I would say I
want to link an application.
I'm going to link an iOS
application or an Android
application or a web
application.
When I do that, the Play
Developer Console
automatically sets up an OAuth
2.0 client ID for me.
I don't need to go and visit
the Google APIs console.
When it sets up that client
ID, it also sets up an
association to that client ID
so that when I log in using
that client ID, the service
knows, OK, this is associated
with the leader boards and
achievements that the
developer has created.
If I were to go and visit the
Google APIs Console, because
maybe I'm a web developer and
this is what I've done in the
past, and I know all about
creating client IDs, I'll be
able to create an OAuth 2.0
client ID, but on the game
services side, it has no idea
that I've gone and done this.
And so when a user signs in to
this client ID, the system is
going to get confused and say,
well, it looks like a valid
login, but I have no
idea what set of
achievements this goes with.
And you'll run into probably
some funky and hard to
diagnose errors, which
are my favorite.
There's one exception to this
rule, which is if you have
created any Google APIs for your
game in the past, when
you create a new project, a
brand new project, on the
Google Play Developer Console,
it will give you a chance to
say, hey, I've already created
some services, maybe using
Drive or something,
with this game.
And during creation time, it
will give you a moment to
specify that project, and it
will go and create some
associations during project
creation time.
But this is the only
time that works.
If after I create this project,
I then go and visit
the Google APIs Console and
create another client, maybe,
I'm going to cause confusion.
So kind of a confusing subject,
particularly because
at some point, you may actually
need to go and visit
the Google APIs Console to do
sort of some weird, tweaky
things, like you need to change
your OAuth redirect or
something, and so it
does get confusing.
But as a general rule, when at
all possible, do everything
from the Google Play Developer
Console and forget that that
old one exists.
DANIEL GALPIN: It was our
opportunity to make things
easier, allow you to do
everything all in one
interface, and I think for some
people it actually made
things more confusing.
And one other thing that's
important to know is just
understanding how OAuth works
is a little bit helpful in
understanding why you have to do
some of the things you have
to do in setting up your game
for Play Game services.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: It's important
to notice that if the same
feature is available through
the APIs Console and the
Developer Console, you should
always prefer to do it from
the Developer Console, because
that's going to set up your
game in the right way
to use your API.
TODD KERPELMAN: It also doesn't
help that we call the
Developer Console the
Developer Console.
That sounds very generic.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And the API
Console the API Console.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
I mean, really, we should be
calling it the Games Console
or something.
DANIEL GALPIN: Exactly.
We've got to have some slick
name for it, like we have for
this laptop.
TODD KERPELMAN: We'll
work on that.
So our next common mistake that
developers run into is
getting throttled.
DANIEL GALPIN: That
sounds painful.
TODD KERPELMAN: It is.
It is very painful
So here's the issue.
When you set up your service,
you'll probably notice, if you
go and visit the Google APIs
Console-- which you generally,
probably shouldn't, because we
just talked about that--
you might notice that your
quota is set to some
incredibly high QPD,
Quota Per Day.
And so you'll get, hey, look
you've 80 gazillion calls you
can make a day.
And developer's, like, great,
I'm going to make
calls all the time.
However, we do throttle similar
calls to a few per
minute, so calls of the exact
same type will get throttled.
What does this mean?
Well, if you're incrementing
four different achievements at
once, that's actually OK.
We have different
limits for that.
And in general, as long as
you're acting reasonable
there, you're OK.
However, if you were to try
and increment the same
achievement, say, four times
in 10 seconds or 10 times a
minute, that's bad, and that
would probably cause about
half of your calls to fail.
What's even more interesting is
half your calls will fail,
but if you were to go and look
up your quota, it would still
say, oh, you're using 0% or 1%
of your quota because that's
really talking about your 80
gazillion calls per day and
not mentioning the fact
that half of your
calls are getting throttled.
The only way you would actually
know you're getting
throttled is to look for error
messages that get returned by
the service and make a note
of those, or log those, or
something like that.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: What if I have
a game that it's a game where
I have to kill enemies, and
then I have an incremental
achievement which is to kill
10 gazillion enemies?
And then how do I do that?
TODD KERPELMAN: That is a very
good question, and that
actually brings us to
our next slide.
Hey, look at that!
Wow.
It's almost like you knew
what my presentation
was going to be about.
So we've got our incremental
achievement.
That's kill 5,000 enemies.
The wrong way to do it, the bad
way to do it, would be to
make an achievement.increment
call every time the player
shoots an enemy.
Let's assume this happens pretty
often, and I'm shooting
enemies left and right.
You don't want to be making
that increment
call all the time.
The best way to do it would be
wait until the end of a round,
or wait until a few seconds have
passed, or something like
that, and then make an increment
call based on the
number of enemies I've killed
up to that point.
So at the end of a round, it
says, oh, look, you've killed
38 enemies, then I can submit
that increment call.
Another mistake I've seen some
developers make is constantly
submitting high scores.
If you're playing a game, and
throughout the game my score
keeps getting higher and higher,
you don't want to be
calling, hey, submit new
high score every time
my score goes up.
Wait until the end of
the game, and then
make that one call.
It is true that, I suppose,
if my game crashes halfway
through, I won't get a chance
to get that partial high
score, but in general, I think
you're better off.
Just wait until the end
of the round, submit
that final high score.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Yeah.
If you're writing a game, and
you don't expect the game to
last for five minutes,
you're pretty much
in trouble, I think.
DANIEL GALPIN: I would say don't
code around the fact
that you expect your game
to crash regularly.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
I supposed you be better off
just making sure your game
doesn't crash.
DANIEL GALPIN: And just to be
clear, at some point we
actually hope to
make it easier.
We actually hope to do some of
this packaging up of multiple
increment.achievement calls
so that you don't have to.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: It looks like
there's room for improvement
on our side there.
TODD KERPELMAN: There's room for
improvement on our side.
We definitely could do a better
job, both in terms of
the library helping to mitigate
this, as well as
letting developers
know that their
calls are being throttled.
Right now, unless you're
analyzing the responses that
come back, it's pretty
hard for you as a
developer to know.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: One thing to
remember is definitely make
sure to submit the high
score when you
get an onStop, though.
Because when you get an onStop,
it might be that your
applicaton's going
to be killed.
So in that case, you definitely
do want to make a
call to that.
DANIEL GALPIN: You really want
to honor the life cycle
whenever possible in all these
things, avoid data loss.
But don't just keep incrementing
the high score
every time you kill the next
alien, because that's just
going to be ridiculous, and our
servers are going to say,
down on that.
TODD KERPELMAN: Right.
By the way, one other issue I've
seen rarely was an issue
where a developer was
constantly checking
achievements.
I believe to actually--
this was sort of as a weird way
of making sure they were
submitting the right number of
incremental achievements, is
they were constantly pinging
our server to be, like, how
much achievement progress
have you made so far?
OK, now that I have this number,
now I know the exact
right amount to increment.
I think this was kind of a bug
that they forgot to cache the
data or something like that.
But if you're calling the same
read multiple times, that can
be just as bad as a write.
DANIEL GALPIN: The thing I
love about working with
platforms is that you really
find incredibly creative ways
that people tend to
misuse your APIs.
So even though this may look
like our mistake, this is
actually your mistake.
So do try to avoid doing
these things.
TODD KERPELMAN: We're sounding
a little defensive.
DANIEL GALPIN: Well, this is
a show about mistakes.
We're making plenty
of mistakes.
So mistake one, we're acting
too defensive.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Let's make
note of our mistakes.
DANIEL GALPIN: Exactly, during
the show about mistakes.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: All right,
so onto the next
mistake, if you will.
Number four, publishing apk but
not the game services, or
vice versa.
So this may be a little
counterintuitive, but an
application and the game
settings are things that are
linked, but they also exist
separately, so you might
actually be able to publish
one without the other.
If you just publish your app,
what's going to happen is that
you're going to have a game
that's published, but your
game settings are not.
Which means that anytime anybody
tries to use a game
API from you game, you're going
to go this weird error
because the game settings
are not published.
You might not see the error
because you probably listed
yourself as a trusted tester on
your own games where you're
going to be able to use
the game's API.
But then whenever anybody else
tries to use that, they're
going to get an error.
So it's important to make sure
that both are published.
The other situation
is also possible.
You might just end up publishing
the game settings,
but then forgetting to
publish the app.
DANIEL GALPIN: But then people
won't see that on Google Play.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
It's less serious than
the other scenario,
but it's also possible.
So you'll definitely want to
make sure that if you're
publishing your game, you want
to publish both the app and
the game settings.
Just taking a look at what the
screens look like, on this
screen, you're publishing
the game setting.
So this is the game setting
screen, And you have this
Publish Game item over there.
So that's publishing
the game settings.
Now this other screen is where
you publish the actual app.
So notice that you are in store
listing, and they don't
even have the Publish App option
over there, and that
causes the actual app
to be published.
So you want to make sure to do
both steps to make sure that
your game can be used outside
of your company.
DANIEL GALPIN: Exactly.
And people may ask, well, why do
you even bother doing this?
And the reality is when you look
at the game life cycle,
you're actually going to want
to do things like add
achievements that your trusted
testers can see before your
actual end users can see it.
So in order to do that, we
actually like to create those
achievements that your trusted
testers can see them
immediately, and then once you
actually publish the game
services with the game data,
then your real users will be
able to see it.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
Suppose, for instance, you
have an existing game on
Google Play, and then you just
want to start working on the
game services, but without
publishing it.
So it makes sense to have the
app published, but not the
game settings.
And then when you're ready to
launch the game services, then
you do that.
Next common mistake is signing
in with an account
that isn't a tester.
TODD KERPELMAN: This is related
to what we were
talking about before.
If you have a set of
achievements or leader boards
that have not been published,
they are only available to
users that are listed
as testers.
Now that means that you need
to go here in this little
testing section of the Google
Play Developer Console and
confirm that the account you're
testing with is, in
fact, listed here among
the test accounts.
Basically, if this doesn't
happen, you'll get sort of
mysterious errors where it'll
sort of be like, yeah, I'm
logged in, but I don't see
any game services.
I don't know what you're
talking about.
These achievements
don't exist.
DANIEL GALPIN: This game
doesn't exist.
You'll actually end up getting
back 404-looking errors.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: It's going to
pretend that it doesn't know
anything about your game.
Like, your game?
Never heard of it.
TODD KERPELMAN: Which is
sort of correct, right?
Like you don't want random
people to try and submit
achievements.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And
probe your game.
TODD KERPELMAN: And
And so, if your set of services,
your achievements,
your leader boards are in a
testable but not published
state, they can only be accessed
by accounts that
you've listed here as testers.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And notice that
even the developer who
published the game settings is
not automatically a tester
unless they have an account
on Google+.
So if your developer account
doesn't have an account on
Google+, you have to also list
yourself as a tester.
So just a general rule, just
list yourself as a tester,
because that prevents
those corner cases.
TODD KERPELMAN: Basically always
go to that Tester tab,
make sure that all the accounts
that you're actually
planning on testing with
are listed there.
Because chances are, some
of them might not be.
DANIEL GALPIN: And that is an
important corner case, though,
to note, that if your publisher
account is Plus
enabled and you try to use it,
bad things will happen.
So do note that.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Next is another
common mistake is to
mistake your client ID for
your app ID in Android.
This is a pretty common one.
And it doesn't help that the
Developer Console gives you
the client ID because the client
ID is what you need for
web and is what you need
for iOS, but for
Android, it's different.
So if you look at an Android
manifest file, you're going to
see that metadata tag that
points to a resource file, and
that resource file
has your app ID.
So the app ID that you want to
make sure is there is this
numerical portion of
your client ID, so
this is only digits.
Now it is a mistake to use the
.apps.googleusercontent.com there.
You only want the numbers
in there.
So that's a pretty
common mistake.
DANIEL GALPIN: And the other
thing to note about this is
there's a reason we put it
into a string resource.
You think, oh, I can just take
that number, and I can paste
it right into the metadata
[INAUDIBLE]
manifest, and it won't work.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Because it
needs to be a string.
DANIEL GALPIN: Because it
And if the XML parser sees
a number in there, it'll
actually turn it into
an integer.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Very
helpfully.
DANIEL GALPIN: Very helpfully.
And then our services will say,
wait, it's not a string,
and will do bad things.
So leave it as a string.
And some people are like,
well, I have to make
resources for this?
But you do, and this is just
part of using it, and it'll
make everything really happy.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Plus it's much
more organized to have this as
a separate resource rather than
having it hard coded into
your Android manifest.
It just looks better.
DANIEL GALPIN: Yeah, right.
Right.
Absolutely.
Because people looking in the
manifest can tell that's the
app ID instead of looking at the
manifest data, which also
says that it's the app ID.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And so,
onto the last mistake
we're going to cover.
Certainly not the last mistake
that we're going to make.
DANIEL GALPIN: No, no.
Several, at least, I've
already made in this
presentation.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: So it's
using the wrong
certificate in Android.
This is actually kind of a deep
topic, so it's useful to
have something of an
understanding of how these
things actually work.
On your device, you
have your game.
So like any Android app, your
game has a package name.
Let's suppose it's
com.example.yourgame, very
creatively.
[INAUDIBLE]
DANIEL GALPIN: It won't let you
publish that package name.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: No, it won't.
DANIEL GALPIN: But this
is just this example.
Don't use this.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
And then your game is, of
course, signed by a certain
certificate, so let's just
assume that that's the
certificate you're
signing with.
DANIEL GALPIN: Very short one.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Very
short one.
And then of course, when you try
to make a game's API call,
what's going to happen is that
the server is going to see if
this game is actually
authorized to
make games API calls.
And the way it does that is it's
going to check your list
of linked apps in the
Developer Console.
So in order for the call to be
authenticated, there needs to
be a linked app that exactly
matches that package name and
certificate fingerprint in
the Developer Console.
So over here, we see that
there's a match because
there's a linked app with
exactly that package name and
exactly that certificate
fingerprint, so the games API
call is going to succeed.
Now if there isn't such a thing,
then you're going to
see an error.
So this is by far the most
common cause of errors.
So to make sure that you're
setting this up right, when
you add a linked app,
you see this screen.
And then you go Save and
Continue, and then the next
step is Authorizing Your App.
And then when you click on
Authorize Your App Now, you're
going to see this
dialogue box.
In this dialogue box, you have
to fill in your package name
and the certificate
fingerprint.
Now this is the step where many
people make a mistake.
You have to take a certificate
fingerprint from your release
certificate that you have
on your machine.
You see, there is this example
there, so this is not an
example that you should use.
It's just here to show you
what it should look like.
DANIEL GALPIN: That's why it
has "example" next to it.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
It's an example.
DANIEL GALPIN: But
unfortunately, a lot of people
will just paste that right in,
and what we should do is we
should catch that.
We should say, hey, don't
use the example string.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: But then what
happens if their certificate
is actually identical
to the example?
DANIEL GALPIN: That's true.
Unlikely, but possible.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Unlikely,
but possible.
Also, you may notice that if you
have an APK that's already
published, maybe there's going
to be a certificate
suggestion over here.
But then you should always make
sure, don't trust that,
and make sure that you're
checking that your certificate
is actually that one.
DANIEL GALPIN: Yeah.
If that suggestion is wrong,
that's our mistake,
unfortunately.
But if you publish it, people
are going to be confused and
not be able to log in.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: It's
always worth
checking out if it's right.
And to do that, you can use the
keytool command line tool.
Essentially to get your debug
certificate fingerprint, this
is the command line.
You just go keytool -exportcert,
and the alias
option is the name of your
certificate, which for your
debug certificate is going
to be androiddebugkey.
And then this is a keystore
file, which is usually in
.android/debug.keystore.
So this is how you get your
debug certificate's
fingerprint.
And then of course, you should
also get your release
certificate's fingerprints,
which you can do using this
command line.
In this case, you're going to
have to replace your keyname
over there and then give the
path to your keystore.
Once you have those two
fingerprints, what we
recommend is that you have two
different client IDs in the
same product with the
same package name.
But those two different client
IDs, one of them has your
debug certificate fingerprint,
and the other one has your
release certificate
fingerprint.
And they exist side by side,
and what this means is that
you can either sign into your
game using your debug
certificate or using your
release certificate.
DANIEL GALPIN: And because we
only allow a limited number of
client IDs for each game, you
should consider using that
debug certificate for all of
your development devices and
for all of your developers.
Because otherwise, you're going
to run out of those
client IDs very, very quickly.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And also if
you delete client IDs,
remember that it takes a really
long time for them to
actually go away.
Because after you delete them,
it takes almost a week until
they actually disappear.
DANIEL GALPIN: Yeah.
This causes a lot of confusion,
and the mistake on
our side is that we don't make
it really clear enough that if
you delete, the delete doesn't
quite automatically happen.
So the best thing to do is
never delete client IDs.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Always create
one with your debug
certificate, one with your
release certificate, and then
hopefully, you're never going to
have to touch those again.
TODD KERPELMAN: As the
non-Android guy in the group,
why do you need two
certificates
in the first place?
Why can't I just use my
release certificate
everywhere?
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: You could, but
then this means that during
debugging, you would always have
to sign your app with the
release keys.
And for some companies,
especially for large
companies, they want to keep
their release keys,
certificates, in a very secure
way, so only certain people
have access to it.
This is to prevent somebody from
grabbing a signed APK and
uploading it into Google Play.
So you might want to safeguard
your release certificate, and
then only work with the debug
certificate during debugging.
And then only at the last step,
when you're actually
going to launch, you sign it
with your release certificate.
DANIEL GALPIN: And it's very,
very easy to take that debug
keystore and simply copy it into
every single one of your
developer's machines and
just use it there.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: It's just
copying a file.
It's easy.
DANIEL GALPIN: Exactly.
And so that's definitely
what we recommend.
And also really do safeguard
your release certificate
because it's really, really
important that
you never lose it.
And that's a non-gameplay
services kind of developer
mistake, but it's a really,
really bad mistake.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Exactly.
And also, we recommend that
you take a look at our
documentation.
We have all of our API calls,
we have the concepts, and we
also have the step-by-step
troubleshooting guide.
So when things go wrong,
you can go into that
troubleshooting guide and go
step-by-step, and then
hopefully, that's going
to help you figure
out what went wrong.
DANIEL GALPIN: And we're not
just saying that because Bruno
and Todd wrote large
chunks of that.
It actually is really helpful.
And you really want to make sure
that when you put a game
out, that you're not ending
up getting bad reviews and
confused users because of simple
mistakes that you could
have corrected early on.
And of course, as we see more
things that happen, we're
going to try to make the
documentation better and better.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: The whole UI
better and better, to make
sure that those mistakes are
more difficult to make.
DANIEL GALPIN: Exactly.
Because ultimately, these
mistakes are a result of
people not understanding
how to implement
our code in our examples.
We really do want to make sure
that the word gets out there
and that things go
very smoothly.
And we've seen a lot of really
excellent implementations
already in the market, and
so we want to keep the
implementations really, really
high quality and keep the user
experience high quality.
TODD KERPELMAN: So what
should developers do
if they have questions?
DANIEL GALPIN: If they have
questions, it really depends
on what platform you're
developing on.
You can always look at the
Android tag and then look up
games or play games services,
as well, when
you're on Stack Overflow.
And we actually regularly
look at these things.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: I usually search
the Android tag and
then anything that has to do
with games, and then just look
at the newest questions there.
DANIEL GALPIN: And you're doing
a similar thing on iOS?
TODD KERPELMAN: Yea.
On iOS, it's hard to look for
iOS in games because there
tends to be a lot of stuff that
isn't Google material.
So I generally look for the
Google Play game services tag.
I've seen that start to
be used fairly often.
And then just look for anything
that doesn't include
Android, which tends
to be a little less
than the Android stuff.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And as always,
of course, make sure to ask
high quality questions.
So include very specific details
about what your setup
looks like, what are the error
message that you're seeing.
If possible include logcat and
everything that might make
your question easier to
understand and debug.
DANIEL GALPIN: Yeah.
There's instructions also in
the game services on how to
turn on logging.
That will help a lot.
Because otherwise, we won't see
anything at all in terms
of errors coming
through logcat.
So you at least want to turn
on logging when you are
submitting questions
to Stack Overflow.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: And I guess
that's pretty much it.
DANIEL GALPIN: I think
that's it.
So I hope you've enjoyed
watching our mistakes, and we
hope that this helps prevent you
from making the same kind
of mistakes that a bunch
of other game
developers have made.
And thank you for your time.
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Thank
you very much.
TODD KERPELMAN: Thanks,
everyone.